[Music]
here's a cell on your screen we have
already seen that the various organelles
inside it are compactly packed inside
this delicate membrane called the cell
membrane or the plasma membrane we've
even seen that the cell membrane makes
use of diffusion process to transport
gas and water molecules in and out of
the cell
however diffusion is not the only
process employed there are a few more on
the list let's have a look at these
methods in this video tell me one thing
how do we transport water from a lower
height to a higher height we need a pump
cause this does not happen on its own a
force or some energy is required to pull
the water upwards similarly in a cell
some molecules have to be carried inside
or moved outside the cell this requires
energy to be spent the energy used is in
the form of ATP molecules this is called
as active transport that is active
transport requires expenditure of energy
the transportation is carried out by
protein molecules present on the cell
membrane on the other hand diffusion
does not require energy hence it's a
type of passive transport so movement of
molecules without spending energy as in
case of diffusion is passive transport
similarly movement of molecules across
the membrane with the expense of energy
is active transport now let's get to
know one more interesting concept named
osmosis
have you ever come across this term
osmosis well quite often but what
exactly do we mean by this osmosis is
defined as the movement of water from
higher water concentration to lower
water concentration through a
semipermeable membrane so let's say we
have this container which is partitioned
by the semipermeable membrane now we add
sugar solutions at both the sides
however the concentration of
each is different here we add
concentrated sugar solution while here
dilute sugar solution that means the
concentration of water in the solution
is obviously more compared to this so
after some time we see water molecules
moving from this side of the partition
did this side and how long will this
movement take place it will occur till
the concentration of water is balanced
that is equalized on both the sides this
is nothing but osmosis let's learn some
more interesting concepts about osmosis
and cell transport in the next video
[Music]